I can't wait till the first stand-up
comedian chat GPT AI guy comes out I
can't wait to see it I can't wait to see
how bad it is let's do a chat gbt joke
right now write a joke about Tom Cruise
in the style of crystallia that's what
he wrote and here it is now I did not
write this chat gbd wrote this you know
what's crazy Tom Cruise runs in every
movie he's in what is the deal with that
it's like what yeah you can't just walk
or take a taxi but no he's gotta run
everywhere he's like the Forest Gump of
action movies I mean have you seen the
Mission Impossible movies that guy is
sprinting all over the place it's like
calm down Tom it's not a marathon but
you know what maybe it is a marathon
maybe it is the Tom Cruise never-ending
running Challenge and the prize being in
more movies I guess I don't know man
guys got energy this is unbelievable you
know what this chat GPT is doing for me
making me realize stuff about Tom Cruise
and Mission Impossible you know the only
thing I would rewrite is Tom Cruise
never-ending running Challenge and the
prize running in more movies would be
funnier than being in more movies how
the [__] do they know what I would do
this is insane this is about artificial
intelligence jokes about what I am in
style of crystallia I did not write this
artificial intelligence huh
what a scam it's like every time I hear
about it I'm like where's the real
intelligence
I mean we've got robots that can play
chess and answer trivia questions but
they still can't fold laundry or make a
sandwich it's like come on AI step up
your game
but you know what maybe we're asking too
much maybe AI is just like us trying to
figure out life and find his purpose
maybe one day robots will run the world
and be like remember when we thought we
were just playing chess oh man how silly
we were but until then I'll just stick
to using it to play video games and have
conversation with random strangers
online that's the AI Revolution this is
terrifying not only is it getting me
nail on the head it's also secretly
telling us what it's doing AI through me
[__] this is [__] up how does it know
I guess it just took my stand up into a
database and or my podcast here's
another one about UFOs humor and style
Chrisley all right here we go UFOs man
what's the deal with by the way I wanna
I want credit with how good I am on
these first reads okay
UFOs man what is the deal why does it
say what's the deal this is like a
[__] Seinfeld thing I'm a hack UFOs
man what's the deal with those things
it's like every time I hear about a
setting I'm like really aliens I mean I
want to believe I really do but it's so
hard with all the fake videos and the
photos out there it's like who do we
believe the government the conspiracy
theorists the people who claim they've
been abducted it's like who do we trust
but you know what maybe that's the point
maybe the aliens are just messing with
us playing a cosmic game of cat and
mouse and maybe one day they'll land
their ships on the White House lawn and
be like
surprise we've been watching it this
whole time and we'll be like
oh my God and then the probably
try to enslave us or something but hey
at least we'll finally have proof of
extraterrestrial life so you know
there's that this is making me feel bad
about my comedy honestly do a Bill Burr
one do it in the style of Bill Burr Tom
Cruise with the humor of Bill Burr this
is absolutely insane to me that chat can
do this Tom Cruise what's up with this
guy I mean he's got more energy than a
five-year-old on the sugar high he it's
like does he ever stop does he ever take
a break does he ever sit down and watch
a movie or read a book or something no
he's always running and jumping and
fighting it's like come on man slow down
you're making the rest of us look bad
but you know what maybe that's the
secret to a success maybe he's got some
kind of superhero ability maybe he's got
some kind of alien blood or something I
don't know man all I know is I can't
keep up with this guy he's like a human
Energizer Bunny he just keeps going and
going and going [__] AI [__] we're
all [__] crazy
[Music]
you're crazy